[Rires]
[Musique]
proposant des gens vous avez refusé
oui je vous propose ma femme et la barre
de fer propos non pas en échange il
propose de racheter votre boîte
prescillia vous propose la somme énorme
qu'est ce que vous dites mais pour le
moment et après s'il ya qui est avec
nous prescillia la dépense hier c'est
suivre mon instinct je vais continuer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans son élan paris
j'étais complètement chabot voilà je me
permets de m'immiscer ce soir dans la
petite lucarne
afin de mieux moins rapide compte rendu
sur cette émission de gaudriole le la
grecque face arrive avec les aides mort
parce que sinon c'est dingue imhoff les
années qui viennent passant j'ai vu
votre métier de libraire jamais rien
fait pour éviter le sodebo acheter sur
mer le terrain de brive la gaillarde à
régler avec les jours fériés
pour marcel blanc est toutefois lui
vous avez jean pierre pernaut va quitter
le jt de tf1 on a peut-être le
remplaçant et jean michel maire
liam 4 ans et parce que quand on sait
dans une ferme des attaquants comme un
bien chargé ses fruits et légumes
ils ont chois ses portes aujourd'hui sur
des asperges qu'il va marier avec
l'incontournable de pâques
chouchou
[Applaudissements]
c'est par ce sens
[Musique]
tu le mets comme ça mme bachmann et tu
te réveilles mon épiderme le matin mais
c'est du moins les états n'en sais pas
les gitanes c'est vraiment c'est une
sélection sans guide
[Musique]